hi my name is jessica boyd i am a
clinical biochemist at alberta precision
laboratories in calgary and i'm also
a clinical associate professor at the
cummings school of medicine at the
university of calgary
today i'm going to be giving a
presentation on laboratory testing for
opioids
with some discussion on uh
interpretation and different
technologies and then how we can use
some data mining techniques to help
customize panels for
clinics in your area
so just briefly my objectives as i
mentioned are disc to discuss
the clinical laboratory and the impact
that the opioid crisis has had
on us as lab professionals discuss the
important factors in setting up a urine
drug screening program
with emphasis on the opioids and then
compare
the available techniques for urine drug
screening for opioids and the challenges
that though each of those technologies
uh presentation
so of course the opioids are very
diverse class of drugs that are used
clinically for analgesia and for opioid
agonist therapy
they are um anything that's an opioid
can
is something that can interact with the
opioid receptors in the nervous system
and they come in three
kind of flavors new kappa and delta and
depending on those drugs interaction
with those receptors you can have
different
impacts different types of effects
of course we know that people who come
in with acute opioid poisoning will
present with a particular toxidrome
some of the features that i've listed
below but of course we
know that in high enough doses um that
type of poisoning is fatal and that is
really what has precipitated
the opioid crisis that we're seeing
today in
especially in north america and where i
am in canada
of course this story started three or
four years ago
when particularly in alberta here for
example we started to see
things like this show up in our illicit
drug supply so on the left-hand picture
we have
a picture of what a normal oxycontin 80
milligram
uh tablet would look like and you can
see it's green it has an 80
uh stamped onto one side or at least
these are the ones that we get anyway
and what we started to see in alberta
and what was being seized by
our local police forces are is shown in
the left-hand
picture which are very similar looking
tablets
they have the same kind of stamping the
same coloration
um the same look to them but they don't
have oxycodone in them
they have fentanyl and fentanyl is much
more potent
and so this was leading to a large
number of people
unfortunately passing away because they
were taking a drug that they weren't
anticipating in their
in their drug supply and so this has
been
the opioid crisis has hit us and canada
very hard and i'm going to show some
statistics
of what opioid poisoning hospitalization
rates have looked like this is data from
2017 but this certainly has not resolved
uh in the past three years and you can
see that this has touched every corner
of our country and it has touched other
countries as well i know the united
states in particular
where i am in alberta which is towards
the western side of the country
we have seen um particularly
high rates of hospitalization vancouver
in bc
has kind of been the epicenter for
canada for this crisis
and that's definitely reflected in these
in these hospitalization
rates and if we were to dig down into
these numbers you would see that this is
also something that's predominantly
affecting
young people so people in the 15 to 40
age group so of course one of the um
big pushes for um the last five years
has been to try
and get the uh identify these
individuals
and get them into a treatment program
and in the province of alberta
our provincial government has um has put
significant amount of resources into
increasing the number of
treatment spots in opioid dependency
programs
and so that has had a very positive
effect
and one of the side effects i guess of
that is that we are seeing
increases in prescribing of drugs like
buprenorphine or suboxone
or methadone as these patients enter
these treatment programs and so this
graph is showing
a steady increase in suboxone dispensing
in alberta and this is a trend that
is continuing into the into 2020
and this is probably what has a bigger
impact on
laboratory testing because of course
these patients are typically
monitored through urine drug screening
to ensure compliance as part of their
program
so in terms of the laboratory impacts
from the opioid crisis
and these are ones that that we felt
here in alberta but i know that are not
exclusive to us in alberta
is we saw huge increase in requests for
urine drug screening starting in about
2015 2016
and i'll show you some data later about
what exactly that looks like and
and show you some of the strategies we
took to try and address that
considering that we're unsure we're all
in a resource finite
environment and there isn't money
necessarily to hire
a whole bunch of new staff or always get
new instruments all the time
but it wasn't just an increase in the
number of drug tests that we were
receiving we were also getting requests
for certain types of tests within the
panel
so of course one of those was fentanyl
prior to 2015 we did not have fentanyl
on our amino acid panels and we probably
honestly didn't think we were ever going
to have to really do it
in large volumes because um fentanyl was
fairly difficult to get a hold of you
had to get it as part of a fentanyl
patch
or diversion from hospital supplies and
so it wasn't as
readily available of course as soon as
some
powders started coming through the mail
containing fentanyl that
definitely changed the situation in
terms of what we needed to do
one of the other big changes was
requests for buprenorphine
testing so again four or five years ago
i would say 98 of our opioid dependency
treatment patients were on methadone
and the switch to buprenorphine has
happened over the last
few years as we try to again increase
treatment spaces um increase the number
of providers who can actually prescribe
this drug get people started in the
emergency department when they're
presenting um and so
now if we were to look at at our data um
i i we have actually more patients on
buprenorphine than we do methadone
so um that was also a major change that
we had to deal with fairly quickly
in 2015-16
so it's always good when we're talking
about setting up or changing a urine
drug screen program
to have an appreciation for what kind of
patient population we're looking at
and of course with the opioids there's
several different areas that this can
touch
so um typically with opioids i'm kind of
thinking of three main areas
for my local area one is emergency
departments
and this is one that often comes up um
in
the news or the literature about you
know what do we do for them
and of course they're the ones seeing
patients presenting for acute opioid
poisoning
and i think it's really important to
remember that um
you know while they may order a urine
drug screen
they're actually um not waiting for the
result of that or they shouldn't be
to be prescribing or administering
naloxone if
someone is showing up with an opioid
toxidrome
and so in these cases the urine drug
screen may be helpful
later to decide what exactly the patient
came in on
but it's not actually particularly
helpful for acute management
and so um you know we're not
necessarily setting up a program to get
results back right away
they've got an antidote and they should
be giving that so where we've really put
our time and our energy
is looking at what the needs of for
example our pain management programs are
but particularly
in my area what the needs of our opioid
dependency treatment programs are
because that's where
people are are moving to hopefully once
they've presented to the ed
the needs of a pain management and
opioid dependency treatment program are
a little bit different than of course
the ed because typically
what they're doing is checking
compliance with prescribed medications
those prescribed medications are not
necessarily the same between those two
groups
of course for opioid dependency programs
uh buprenorphine
and methadone are probably two important
ones
but your pain management providers may
be using a whole variety of things and
it's important to understand
what they're using so that those can be
on your panel and of course
we always usually have some of the other
commonly used drugs or drug classes so
then those are amphetamines or what not
because we're also looking to make sure
that they're not
taking other things perhaps in addition
to their
prescriptions
so in terms of the laboratory process
for drugs with abuse testing this is
a pretty standard process used by many
labs
um and it's usually a two-step process
where we have some sort of screen
using an amino acid um
and then depending on some sort of
criteria sometimes it's
you know all positive sometimes it's
certain positives
then they go on for confirmation testing
by mass spectrometry
in my lab we have both of these
technologies so we're able to control
in-house what goes where i know there
are many areas that do not have
mass spectrometry on site and it's an
expensive referral test and so
controlling what goes out for mass spec
is
is more of an issue but i i'm hoping to
show you by the end of this
talk why having mass spectrometry
available for the opioids
um is important um due to the the
limitations of immunoassay screening and
which is really
it really is a screen and it is not a
definitive result
so of course amino acids are present uh
in many places and as i mentioned that
they may be the only
type of uh testing available on site
and there's reasons for this they are
pretty simple to perform
you can get the result pretty quickly
and they can be performed at the point
of collection and there are
point-of-care programs set up for these
but
it is really important to remember that
amino assays
are prone to false positives they're
prone to false negatives
and within that test itself it cannot
tell you
if that is a false negative or a false
positive we just know that there was
reactivity with an
antibody within the test and so these
results
require confirmation by mass
spectrometry
um and um otherwise you can't tell
whether this was something actually an
opioid
in some of these tests which opioid um
or whether it was something that's not
an opioid but just happens to
cross-react with the antibody so this is
the real strength of mass spectrometry
for
this type of testing
so i just want to take a few minutes and
talk a little bit about opioid
versus opiate nomenclature because this
is also very important for understanding
the interpretation of these tests
often opioid and opiate are used
interchangeably but they are not the
same thing and in this table
i've shown a kind of an overview of how
they
how they work together so opioid is
an umbrella term that refers to anything
that can
interact with the opioid receptor
essentially um
and so everything in this table and like
i said this isn't an
exhaustive table but all of these would
be opioids
the opiates are in the left-hand column
and those uh typically refer to the
opioids that can be derived from the
opium poppy so we're talking primarily
about morphine and codeine
and i've put a structure down at the
bottom so that you can see
that they have a five ring structure
with different side groups at kind of
three different places on the backbone
that change whether it's you know
morphine coating or metabolite
in the middle column we have the
semisynthetic opioids
and i've thrown things like hydrocodone
hydromorphone in here
now hydrocodone hydromorphone are
metabolites of morphine and codeine
but when we're talking about urine drug
screening
um we know that actually despite being
metabolites
of morphine codeine they don't actually
react
as well as morphine encoding in the
urine opiates amino acid
um in fact in our assay locally for
example
uh we get about 50 reactivity meaning
that we need
twice as much of hydrocodone and
hydromorphone
in the urine to get the same response
as morphine and codeine and so that's a
big source of false negative results and
why
at my institution if if my staff see
that a patient is on one of these
we actually just send it straight to
mass effect
i put oxycodone here as well oxycodone
may or may not react with your urine
opiates assay and ours it doesn't react
at all
but again if the assumption is that a
urine ops assay reacts with
all opioids and it's not understood that
it really is just
picking up morphine and codeine um then
that can be
a perceived i guess false negative and
then in the right hand column we have
the synthetic opioids
this includes things like methadone
fentanyl buprenorphine
and these ones really there is no
reactivity in the urine opiates assay
at all and you need to have a separate
amino acid for testing for these
and you can see at the bottom um the
structures are quite different they
don't even
have that fibrin backbone anymore and so
that kind of
you know visually can help make help us
understand why that antibody may not
pick that up
metabolism is also really important to
understand for urine drug screens
because in urine
typically it's the metabolite that we're
seeing at the highest concentration not
the parent
and so one of the most common calls i
get is understanding how
codeine morphine and heroin and their
various metabolites
go together on our drug screen panels so
in the middle
you can see codeine and morphine here
um codeine of course is a pro drug
morphine is
is what we want it to metabolize to once
you've taken it
um i've already mentioned that both of
those can also be metabolized to
hydrocodone and hydromorphone those are
at the top of the screen
they're minor metabolites but they are
active but they can also be given as
drugs themselves
towards the bottom of the screen we have
the inactive metabolites and the
glucuroni
um so nor morphine and then glucuronide
glucoronidated forms and then on the
right upper
side of this diagram you see where
heroin can
fit into this uh into this pathway and
it's
heroin and will metabolize the six
monoacetyl morphine or six mam
which then metabolizes to morphine so
in a urine opiate assay i've already
told you that it will pick up
primarily codeine and morphine but
depending on your assay
you may have cross reactivity with six
monoacetylmorphine or heroin
um and for the assay we use locally does
pick both of those up
so this is another caution about acting
on a urine opiates result
because if it's positive even if it's a
true positive
you don't know whether that positive is
coming from codeine presence
morphine being present or heroin and its
metabolite being present potentially
so again why mass spectrometry is really
important so that we can speciate those
out
and give that information to the
physician
this is just a simple diagram for some
of the other
opioids that we're typically looking at
they're a little bit more simple than
the codeine morphine
group um so typically we're looking at
you know one uh parent one metabolite
pair
um you can see that buprenorphine also
has some glucoronides floating around
there
um and here um just would point out
that for methadone and buprenorphine we
actually
monitor even on our immunoassays at
least for methadone
both the parent and the metabolite and
the reason that we do that
is because we're trying to pick up
people who might be adding
some of their methadone or buprenorphine
to their urine an attempt to fool the
drug screen
um the drug screen i guess isn't being
fooled there would be actually the
methadone in the urine
but if it's present without the
metabolite or without
um significant amounts of metabolite it
suggests that there was some
adulteration of the urine and so that's
a practice that we've done for quite a
long time locally
for our opioid dependency clinics
so what immunoassays are available for
testing of opioids and urine so i've
i've made a list here this is not fully
exhaustive but it's
there to give you an idea that there are
lots of options and you could put a
whole bunch of opiate amino acids on
your wet or your chemistry analyzer
but it's going to start taking up a lot
of room at some point and so this is
again
back to knowing what your population is
and knowing which of these tests are
actually useful
to have on your instrument
it is really important to note here that
cross your activity is going to vary
between the vendors
so make sure you take a look at the
package insert and understand
um you know what your opiates assay is
it reacting with heroin and system and
particularly well is it not
if it's not you may need to have a
separate heroin metabolite assay
um what's your cross reactivity with
hydrocortisone hydromorphone or do you
need to look at having a separate
immunoassay for that
um another thing to pay attention to are
cut
the opac for example usually comes with
two different cutoffs
a clinical and
workplace cut off and you what you pick
may depend again on your population and
maybe also on your resources for sending
out from aspect if you don't have it on
on site so this is understanding your
reflex
algorithm may also play a role in that
as well
now because of all of the assays that we
would potentially be looking at to put
on our instruments
and the fact that we really don't at my
institution didn't have room to put all
of these on and that these are all still
even if they're targeting you know
hydrocodone or fentanyl specifically
that amino acids are still not
definitive results but
so the decision that we did at our
institution was to start moving all of
this onto mass spec
um to kind of bypass all the
interpretive issues that we see with
with immunoassays and also the amount of
testing that we would need
um and so we are in the process of like
i said of discontinuing most of our
immunoassays in favor of mass
spectrometry
and the way that we've decided to do
this is through
liquid chromatography tandem mass
spectrometry
using targeted analysis with mrm uh
multiple reaction monitoring scans so
this picture in the middle here is a
picture of a triple quadrupole
uh and it is uh in mrm um
mrm mode and if you don't know what that
is essentially um
what we do in the q1 box is we tell the
instrument to only allow the ions of a
certain
molecular um sorry charge
mass to charge ratio um so for example
we should know as part of method
development what the mass to charge
ratio of morphine would be
so we'll tell the instrument only allow
the morphine mass to charge ratio
through
now of course there is a possibility
that there is another molecule in that
sample that has the same
mass to charge as morphine floating
around if you've done your
chromatography well
you may have separated it already but
in case you didn't the mass spec allows
you another
opportunity to filter that out then it
does that
by fragmenting that massive charge in q2
to produce product ions and then again
as part of our method development we
would have identified the major product
ions of morphine
and told the instrument okay these are
the top two or three product ions of
morphine
and we only want that to transit to the
detector at any given time and so that
will give us our mrn signal
on the right hand side and so typically
in any one of our drug screen
analyses we'd be monitoring at least two
of these transitions per analyte
um and we are able to do this
simultaneously so that we can look at
all of these opioids
you know and other classes of drugs at
the same time
the downside of this of course is that
um
if there is something around in in the
urine
that is not on your list that you've
pre-defined with the instrument you're
not going to see it
um and so this is um this is definitely
a downside in that
picking up new drug trends is difficult
with analyzing your samples as well
but we made the decision to go this way
because we had so many samples that we
um
we needed to get through that it was
more important to kind of look for the
the key ones and then we would kind of
do work with our partners
in the province to work on identifying
uh new drugs that we
may need to add the other advantage of
mass spectrometry
particularly if you're doing it as a lab
develop test or an ldt
is that you can add new analytes
yourself
it does require method development and
you may need to go muck around with your
with your method to get it to work
but typically you can add those new
analytes if you can find a standard
a lot sooner than it would take for a
new immunoassay test to be developed
um if you've been paying attention to
the news you know we've seen over the
last five years
you know several new um drugs kind of
start to show up in the drug supply
along with fentanyl carfentanyl as an
example
and that's one that we added to our mass
spec panels
um and i don't um i think i've only seen
one or two little point of care
devices so far for carfentanil i'm sure
people are working on it so
you you can potentially move a bit
faster on some of these new emerging
drugs as well
so just to give you an example of what
one of our opioid panels looks like
um this has all of our kind of
important parents and metabolites from
codeine
and morphine metabolism we have
methadone and
dpp buprenorphine or buprenorphine
oxycodone or oxycodone fentanyl nor
fentanyl
and so the real power here is that
you're able to monitor for all of these
simultaneously
in one sample and so i can look at it
and go
um are the are the coding
or the what we see in terms of morphine
coding nor coding
does that look like a codeine pattern
does it look like maybe they're taking
hydrocodone hydromorphone separately
um and so it gives me a lot more
information than if i'm just trying to
decipher
an amino acid result for all of these
so in the last few minutes i just wanted
to show you some of what we've done in
calgary to try and address
uh the our our issues with the opioid
epidemic
um you can see here a graph of
our workload volumes and requests for
urine drug screens
between 2010 and 2017 and you can see
that
you know prior to 2015 we had pretty
stable
direct screen requests it was it was
pretty much the same number plus or
minus
you know five percent very predictable
we had totally
arranged our staffing and our
instrumentation usage around it because
you know we didn't have any major
changes
you can see in 2012 we did see an
increase but that's because we had a new
clinic coming on board and we knew that
was happening so it actually made
um it was fairly easy to plan um like i
said our staffing
and workflow around this but in 2015
but particularly 2016 and 17 as fentanyl
started to show up
in the drug supply in alberta we started
to see
those numbers shoot way up and we
actually saw a doubling
of our volume over two or three years
which
really threw our entire process out of
whack
we were not able to keep up with the
samples coming in
we had to start doing elaborate sorting
processes
to make sure that we were getting kind
of ed
and hospital samples out and we would do
opioid dependency samples later because
that would take us probably two or three
weeks
at one point it was taking us seven or
eight weeks to actually get those
results out which is starting to impact
the match in both patients as well
and so we knew our process was not
sustainable needed some major changes
and so we went to the drawing board to
kind of decide what we were going to do
and part of
the decision at that time was to start
moving
all of our samples to a fully lcm sms
process a targeted panel so we would you
know
have you know 20 or 30 drugs on that
panel
we would use
automated liquid handling to extract our
samples which we were doing manually
before then and then we would
get middleware to connect our
instruments to the lif so that
we didn't have someone manually putting
results in
as we were doing in 2014
but part of the big question there was
well what
what do we need on these panels and and
um
are we going to have one panel for
everybody or are we going to have
customized for certain user groups
within our population because we do
we do all the urine drug screening in
southern alberta so we cover
everybody and so what we did there
to address that question was to do a
retrospective data analysis of our urine
drug screens
to see who is ordering them what drugs
are we seeing commonly in our population
and i've got some of the summary
information here
we did just over 50 000 drug screens
over a four year period
that represented just over 12 000
individual patients
and on average we were seeing four uh
just over four
drug screens per patient over that time
period
um but of course we had quite a big
range on that you know majority of those
patients were coming in with just one
drug screen because they may have
against emergency department or
something but then we would have
a large cohort of our our patients who
were
opioid dependency program members and so
we're coming in
regularly to have samples and so we had
one individual over that four
year period who had over 100 drug
screens
so definitely showed us that we had
different groups within our population
so who ordered the most drug screens
when we broke it down by
ordering provider it was very clear and
and i think we knew this before
that um addictions medicine
was the number one requester and the
majority of those
were opioid dependency clinics and so
we wanted to definitely work with that
group to figure out
how this process was going to work
because they were also represented most
of our repeat
customers
so one of the biggest users within the
addictions medicine group was physician
a
uh this was the sole physician at the
largest methadone clinic in calgary
he had actually kind of spearheaded a
lot of the methadone treatment
more than 10 years before and so
um was very knowledgeable and had been
around for a long time and some new
patients really well
and he actually represented he his
patients
cohort represented a quarter of our
total workload so obviously getting him
on board with any changes we were doing
was
was extremely important
so um i did a as part of a data poll i
looked at what
drugs we were detecting within his
population and so it's not really
surprised that
majority majority of the positive drugs
in his population was methadone and at
the time as i mentioned earlier
methadone was the primary drug
um being used for opioid dependency at
that time
and you can see that 88 of the
assessments received from that
that clinic population were positive um
then looking down the rest of this list
and this is just kind of the top
grouping we see morphine codeine
diphenhydramine ibuprofen oxycodone
and so we wanted but the the numbers are
dropping off in terms of percent
positive
quite rapidly and so um you know i had a
very long list of things that you know
were less than one percent positive and
so we wanted to make sure we were
pulling out kind of the
the really um relevant most commonly
detected drugs
out of his uh population for a panel
um so what i proposed to him was this
panel
which was an lcms targeted panel
that had of course methadone edp at that
time
his clinic wasn't prescribing
buprenorphine but we did add
buprenorphine
later we have morphine codeine 6-man
oxycodone and metabolites cocaine
fentanyl nor fentanyl acetylene
methamphetamine
and so we went and met with him and said
what do you think these are the issues
that we're having
moving to this panel would allow us to
give you your results in a
less than one week time frame as opposed
to the seven or eight week
time frame that we were dealing with at
the time
and so we had a really good we had a
really good discussion with him
he um he definitely understood the
problems that we were facing and he was
definitely motivated
to help us find a way to get his samples
back
to him sooner he was also um
one of the big advocates for making sure
that they could have access to lcms
because he understood
all of the issues with the immunoassay
interpretation
um and so he actually wanted all of his
patients to go to mass spec if we could
accommodate that and so this was one of
the ways that we said that we could
potentially do that
we also discussed the data pool that we
had done and
presented the proposed lcms panel and
had a really good discussion with him
about it
um and so after that discussion we ended
up expanding the panel slightly to 21
drugs we kept those
the opioids amphetamines we added a few
benzodiazepines that he had said he was
having
problems with from his population
although
you know we're looking at the drug
screen side and saying that you know
they're not detected often but you know
it's the feedback of what
the physician is getting from his
patients or her patients is really
important as well
we kept cocaine and added a few
adulterants that were commonly seen in
our population
we added a urine ethanol screen and some
antidepressants so
those are the ones that he felt were
really important for his
for helping him to manage his patient
and moving to 21 drugs on that panel
um wasn't too onerous on our side to
make sure that we were able to actually
move to this process
and discontinue kind of our old process
that was
that was really hindering us at that
point
so we did a similar process with the
other seven
opioid dependency clinics that we had at
that time
and so all of them actually had pretty
much this
a very similar backbone of um a panel
and then
we did a few kind of customizations
depending on what they were seeing
particularly in their population
um as i mentioned we added automation
steps for this
as well so that we had a robot doing a
sample prep and we interfaced
directly to the lif so that results
could be released directly
and so now uh we can prepare analyze and
result
multiple 96 well plates per day if if
needed
and we have capacity uh to handle
further increases in our workload volume
which is really important
with our old process i should mention
that we probably on a good day
and if we had our really experienced
technologist doing the
data interpretation we could maybe get
20 to 30 samples out
so this represents a significant
increase
in our throughput and over the past um
two or three years um we really haven't
had any issues with samples piling up
because this process is able to allow us
to
get those samples out quickly and it
allows us to give an lc an sms result
directly to our clinicians which i think
they appreciate very much as well
so in summary the opioid epidemic has
had
significant impacts on health care
including laboratory medicine
particularly for us for urine drug
screening testing
immunoassay screens are convenient but
they
have major issues in terms of false
positives and false negatives
um and so mass spectrometry is really
such a useful tool for allowing us to
monitor parents and metabolites in a
sample to speciate those all
out individually and give us a
definitive result
and so if you have the opportunity to do
mass spec
on these samples it's i think it really
does provide
much better information on amino acid
drug screening
and uh finally retrospective data mining
can help
help you guide your drug screen panel
development if you if you've got that
information
and help open that conversation with
your physicians about
what might be appropriate for their for
their clinics
so in conclusion or acknowledgement i'd
like to acknowledge
dr hussain savaday who is my co-director
for the analytical toxicology department
and also the section chief of
biochemistry
at apl calgary uh dr chris knogler
and of course all of my colleagues in
the clinical biochemistry department in
calgary
and with that i'm happy to take any
questions
that will be forwarded to me thank you
very much